et vous c'est bien ce que chante paris
aimons tant que et saint denis
le roi de france c'est bon le vive le
roi d'harcourt et moi l'euro d'arosa me
fais pas ça me fait ch ou je remercie
fiction le serrurier qu'avant j'ai la
bonne clé
et karine qui l'a endormi les soldats
et chez les gros doigts qui a tordu le
cou du roi mois - darfour
j'attendais ça
les pieds gelés et la fleur au chapeau
merdier de la cour des miracles vouer
à la peau
j'en rêvais déjà
je suis né de la grosse amende
sur un grabat de la cour des miracles
regardez bien vous l'avez jamais vu en
demies roire et de stature de lustres de
cristal aux chandelles de vienne me de
chaises ou le cul peut arrondir comme un
salaire
pas tendre à vatan faire les lits où
dormira qu'il veut dans
et que les autres scènes à même le tapis
qu'il soit bête à bon dieu bet at home
est à plaisir
ce pas l'air
je m'y installe et j'en fais un bandeau
poussé valley nous par un des murs à
jouer
je serai chez moi
quand j'aurai fait de ce noble château
le cul de sac de la cour et meerab
vous les abbruzes j'avais peur de vous
temmar et son fils el-ater vous les
filles et un soldat vous aurez des
bichons est dépité d'argent pour
apprécier un bon petit écran
tricherie
je vais organiser je vais colonisés il
fallait temps voyons pour un joli
refrain vieux fait
moi moi moi d'amour
de force et de droit
bah je veux d'abord que l'on créé
manteau nom en souvenir de la cour des
miracles ou et au revoir
je le sais déjà
je suis tombé sur un drôle de bâton bien
plus pourri que la cour des miracles